we are not going as Molly what who do
you think is best for our thesis
character is it Nance fern is it Lauren
is it Daniel who do you think you know
what's crazy
I honestly think that ether deep
couldn't make it work with either one of
those guys anyone it's just which ether
and which version of those guys right
I think Lawrence now would be phenomenal
but I also think you don't get Lawrence
now until you get like heartbreak
Lawrence and like chlamydia lord I guess
I guess that's like what guys dude is
get get to hurt out the system hmm
sure and then they contract some level
and then they go to church you don't say
it's like it's a whole circus ho in my
way Oh wimoweh and so I it's like I
don't do you get this do you get this
version of Lawrence if ISA
doesn't get that up he's Danny that's
the reality of life like every blessing
in life teaches you something every
transition in life should teach you a
lesson and so then it's like Daniel is
cool but remember when Daniel was just a
knight in shining armor it was just like
he can do the wrong and then you saw his
insecurities but I still think that like
he still could have been good for him
but ESA's like I can't be good for you
and I'm trying to get for myself right
so is this kind of like it sounds like
it's timing it's just all time good hope
a visa yeah it wasn't right for Daniel
and when Daniel was trying to be serious
serious wasn't that you were just an
inch I need to describe everybody's
circling each other right and man
stirred up so those make the Nathan Navy
I think he inspires her to be a
different version of her son because
it's also they don't have that history
yeah you know what Daniel was like he's
a cutie
and so it was like they always had that
history so it's like you know too much
almost like that guy that like you're
almost guarded with but then you pull
down your guard but but then they can
hit you with those daggers because they
know your past how do can tiger uppercut
all the nineties babies yeah but Nance
Kurt is new yeah he's just new and
everything that comes with new is like
yours discovery and it's the excitement
of discovery that's why when you go it's
kind of like jarring because it's like I
let you in and because you said all the
right things you did all the right
things and we were growing and I was
learning and God you can't text go buddy
back Nathan I'll be pressed I'll be
pressed you're not press
[Music]